foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsay personality George
Campbell Join This Hour by best-selling
author and host of the Ken Coleman show
you guest at americed Ken Coleman
himself and we are excited to take your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you want to talk
about getting out of debt getting on a
budget Building Wealth paying off the
house switching jobs getting a side
hustle we can talk about all that stuff
yeah absolutely you know Dave has said
for decades that your income is your
greatest wealth building tool and I'm
the personality that specializes in
making more money but also experiencing
more meaning so increase the income
increase your impact it is possible now
more than ever uh
you're good at that yeah well you know
I'm a preacher's kid so I speak in
alliteration I can't help myself it's
memorable it is so there you go let's do
it let's do it J's kicking us off in San
Diego AJ welcome to the show
hey George hey Ken thanks for taking my
call sure how can we help
so um I've got a career question
um I I want to know how to plan for the
future here I'm very very fortunate uh
financially but my concern is around the
culture in my in my company I work for a
small investment brokerage not many
people run heavily from the top down and
if it was just a on a financial basis I
would stay here forever I like what I do
I like building relationships and sales
but like I say it's just kind of the
culture that you know has me concerned
from a principal standpoint what
specifically or what are you comfortable
sharing as it relates to this culture
stuff that's wanting you to driving you
crazy making you want to leave
uh it's coming from the top down and so
in this in this role it's uh you know
commission-based job with preset you
know
um percentages or commissions if you
will and
um I think because for a small group and
and just the dynamic of it my managing
broker uh will you know dip his hand
into the pot and okay I want you to be
more specific so AJ you're saying you
don't agree with the com structure and
you feel like your boss is stealing from
you
yeah the com structure is very clear but
the comp structure is not followed
um I can give you an example that's what
I'm looking for you give me an example
perfect so this will happen one every
four or five deals
um where uh so we did a deal just
recently to close that
um
you know the total Commission on the
deal was 70 000 uh give or take my comp
on the deal
um based on our contract is 35
000 I end up with 20.
so you're supposed to get 50 of any
Commission
right yeah well what was the reason
given was there any reason given for why
you took a fifteen thousand dollar hit
on a on a commission that is laid out
clearly in your employment agreement
yeah the reason is the same as it always
is I'm I'm good to you I give you
opportunity and
um you know so I'm I'm just not changing
it okay so what's your question because
I'm ready to rip this leader of yours as
this This Disaster this this bad boss
this this is this is manipulation it's
it's horrible oh I couldn't hold it in
George what was your question
yeah I know what it is from a
psychological standpoint
um the reason I'm still holding on is
because at the end of the day
I still do really well here and you know
I wonder am I gonna I feel like I'm
winning a lottery ticket as far as
income and am I going to get that
somewhere else okay so what do you sell
real estate okay bro
um first of all if you're good at
selling real estate you can sell real
estate for anybody anywhere anytime but
this is eating away at you
and it should for sure I know and listen
it's not going to get better
I'm gonna call you out on something
because I'm your friend
I think you're scared I think you're
scared to leave because I think you
don't you don't believe you can do what
you're doing anywhere else I think
that's pretty apparent and so I think
you got some fear maybe some doubt and I
think that's what's keeping you there
but let me tell you something you either
overcome this fear and doubt and leave
or
you're going to become so resentful so
bitter and something bad is going to
happen as opposed to you taking control
of your life and not be treated this way
that's a great point I know
so AJ I only see two options here either
you leave or you deal with it and go hey
I'm going to set up a meeting with
another leader bring them into it and
say Here's what's going on I need a
solution for this
can you do that is there another leader
that you can involve no it's it's such a
small team there's there's six of us and
I'm you know so is that person basically
the CEO are they running the company
yeah yeah it's manipulation it's over
the today was the day we decided now
we're gonna go find another broker
or another firm or whatever and you're
gonna relationship yourself into this
okay your head's gonna be high
shoulders back and you're gonna be bold
because you know you can sell so go
right go where you're treated properly
you have not hit the lottery at all in
fact the next job where you actually get
paid your full commission that might
feel like you hit the lottery but right
now you're you're being manipulated
it's true I mean that you know the one
caveat being is no Carolina business
comes in and he he does you know hand it
out right does it matter it doesn't
matter you feel like a victim right now
you're like a dog that's been hit its
whole life
and every time every time he hits you
every time you hit that dog it's like
the dog going well he does feed me
consistently brings a lot of food home
who cares man every time that he takes
from your commission that is rightfully
yours based on the agreement that he
made or she made with you it is
absolutely manipulating you and it is
destructive and you have bought the
narrative you've bought the lie because
you don't think you can go to us this
listen this is done
there's nothing there's no more caveats
mm-hmm and so from a career perspective
um I don't you know I almost feel like I
I like the business I want to I want to
go off someday and do it myself I want
to be you know the managing broker of my
own business so do I do I stick out
until I feel ready to do that I feel
like no you'll never be ready my man no
just gotta start
would you would you tell someone to stay
in a place where they're just being
abused
no no don't stay stay in the business
but go work for somebody else and then
when we make this next move here's what
I want you focusing on what do I need to
learn that I don't know now that will
set me up and put me in a place where I
could work for myself and we're gonna go
get that experience go get that
knowledge do you understand
yeah it's awesome that's what I've been
thinking about do it stop thinking
awesome thanks guys all right you got it
man man that lack of Integrity we're not
moving past that it's time it's not
gonna change this guy is who he says he
is 100 and bold about it hey I bring it
to you I take care of you I'm gonna not
give you your full commission this time
yeah
open the ring what are we doing no
thanks Tom Hanks that's what I gotta say
to that Ken
spicy Friday give us a call Triple eight
eight two five five two two five this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by Ken
Coleman we are taking your calls about
life money career The Pursuit of
Happiness impact and income it's all
here on the Ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five Patty
joins us up next in Austin Texas Patty
welcome to the show
hey thanks for taking my call absolutely
what's going on
so
um I uh so we have a decision to make as
a family uh we are currently staying in
Austin we bought a home uh we closed the
home last year in uh November so we have
been staying in this house for since
March of this year uh my wife got a new
job offer in California and we were
wondering if moving to California does
it make sense based on the salary height
that she is getting and if yes then what
do we need to do with this house we
don't want to sell it so does renting
this house makes sense
Okay so
excitement level on a scale of one to
ten one being no excitement ten being
throwing a party how excited is your
wife and then how excited are you about
the potential of moving to California
for this job
I think my wife is pretty excited not
because it's California just because of
the role so that she's getting [ __ ] like
the company and everything and I think
it's it's going to be a good good
project for us going forward so okay
and I'm also very supportive of her
because I can in my job I can work from
anywhere yeah so just financially does
it make sense that's the question well
so on the financial piece break it down
for George and I so uh what's the what's
the cost of living increase uh from her
standpoint is she getting a nice bump in
salary
right so I'll walk you through our
current situation and then the situation
in California so all all in Gross uh
income so right now I make 140 uh 140
000 she makes 125 000 days plus each of
us uh in total would make uh are making
close to 29 000 in bonuses
um each year so total income you can say
294 000 right now in Texas
um when we moved to California I'm
assuming my salary is going to stay same
that's the worst case scenario right so
I'll be making same 140 uh base but she
is getting 195 000. okay uh in
California plus uh bonus structure will
remain same but because uh her base is
increasing so the bonus would be around
33 500 right so total would be 368
000 uh dollars plus she's also getting
stocks and yearly that the stock listing
is close to a hundred thousand dollars
so we're talking about a 70k bump in
income and so then it comes down to the
math of we know the taxes are going to
be higher the cost of living is going to
be higher in California does that equate
to under 70 000
towards still a net win yeah guys
uh so even when I put so in this
assumption I'm thinking that our current
home would go on rent
so even in that terms if I make that
assumption I would we would be saving
close to ten thousand four hundred
dollars more compared to what we do here
yearly okay in California how much do
you owe on the home in Austin
uh close to 340. what's it what's it
worth if you sold it today
I checked everything that says 525
okay and then what price point have you
done your homework on homes and what
they cost in the area where you guys are
going to be living
I don't think I'm going to buy property
in California so soon uh so we would be
renting uh at least for next couple of
years in California for sure yeah if I'm
in your shoes I'm selling your property
in Austin I'm with you for a few reasons
number one being a long-distance
landlord is a recipe for disaster yeah
and number two you guys aren't in a
financial position obviously the income
is great
but you're going to be paying rent on
top of hoping that you have a
responsible tenant who pays on time that
can pay the mortgage right that's always
I put that in air quotes you can't see
unless you're watching but that's the
part that worries me and so I would get
I know it's it's there may be a stupid
tax involved here because you guys just
moved in recently and so after realtor
fees and it may not have appreciated
that much you're gonna have to pay
capital gains on the profits
as well because you've only been there
for a few months correct
yeah so I mean she's still after joining
the job so she still has six months to
eight months to move to California so I
think we can stay one year in this
property and make it a long-term capital
gain instead of custom that's better at
least yeah so I'm still selling it I
think you guys will leave with uh what
116 change in equity
right that can help kick-start your
journey in California and if you're in
California long term you're going to
want to buy something even though it's
insane and that might mean you save up
six hundred thousand dollars with your
amazing income and buy a 900 000
property years from now
okay and another thing that I was
thinking what if we pay off this
property that does it make sense to hold
on this property and rent it out without
still paying off it doesn't make sense
and still you're still a long distance
landlord the question is when you're in
California would you go buy a house in
Austin to rent out
right yeah the answer is probably no
no and so I think the time to be a real
estate investor is once we can pay cash
for another property and our current
home is paid off and you guys can do
that I mean with this income it won't
take long for you guys to do that if you
keep living on less than you may can be
you're clearly very intentional you're a
super smart guy and so I think you can
get there but right now that wouldn't be
my go-to I have a follow-up question
Patty is this a uh a hybrid model well
even if you were to move to California
will she be required to be in the office
every day do you know that because I
know she's working remote for a season
in Austin
yeah she has to be in office it's a
manufacturing company
and you've looked at rent in that area
that's close by to her work
yeah it's so worst come worse it would
be like if we go for a single family
home it would be around four thousand
four thousand two hundred dollars wow
but we can move into apartment I mean we
have been staying in apartment from past
20 yeah 15 years as long as that rent is
about 25 of your take-home pay that
leaves you with plenty of margin to live
the rest of your life invest fifteen
percent of your income into retirement
pay off the house early do you guys have
kids
no no Casey okay did she get recruited
on this or did she go seek this position
um
yeah she has a pretty good experience in
launching on electric vehicles she used
to work for Tesla before okay let me ask
you this this is this is a very quick
point but I gotta know if if a company
in Texas had
had called
and offered the same position
um and and so you have now one in in
Texas and one in California which one
which which is let's say was the same
thing which one would you all take
Texas yeah I got to tell you
um
when someone recruits you it feels
really good it does it feels good to be
wanted
um right but I I just wonder if long
term financially if you guys if if she
doesn't go all right what if I look for
something in a different state that's
not as expensive what if I look for
something in the Texas area and I can
further my career in Texas you don't
have to take every good offer because
I'm just I just want to throw it out
there I'm not in any way trying to talk
you out of going to California at all
I'm not anti-california but I'm being
very realistic on the financial
implications of moving to California to
to to do something that she can do in
another state so if it were me I I would
be sitting down going okay if we want to
move up can we move up in other places
do we have to take this opportunity
which is a good opportunity I don't know
that this is a great opportunity you you
may think it is and if you think it is
then do it but I at least wanted to put
that out there are they paying any
relocation costs
and check out the area figure out what
the different neighborhoods are where
you want to rent and that'll make you
feel a little more peace about the move
in case you do it yeah I think to Ken's
point it doesn't have to happen and so
think about the future and what you guys
want to do long term as well I just have
so many friends that are moving here uh
in our state where we have no state
income tax and the amount of money they
are making by simply moving out of a
high-tech State it's it's realistic
sometimes or to your point George how
much money and how long it takes to save
up a money to just buy a house save up
money to buy a house in a state like
that where real estate is so high it's
you got to think about the big picture
well they have a great shovel at least
and that helps with this whole situation
absolutely way to go this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com Ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
foreign
[Music]
I feel like right now is the time of
year when it's make or break when it
comes to our goals we had a reset when
school started again and now we're
heading into a holiday season and let's
be real it's hard to stay motivated one
says spending frenzy starts we've all
got goals whether it's to find a better
job make more money pay off some debt
build stronger relationships and it can
be hard to keep that momentum going but
here's the good news coming up in a
couple weeks we have one of our biggest
events smart conference we're coming to
Dallas Texas for a day-long jam-packed
event where you'll get advice from
leading experts on money personal growth
career mental health and your marriage
you're going to leave with all the
knowledge and motivation you need to
reach your goals and live the life that
you want so join me and the rest of the
gang all the Ramsey personalities will
be available be there Dave Ramsey Dr
John deloney Ken Coleman Christina Ellis
uh Rachel Cruz it's going to be a good
time it's a special event and by the way
it's more than just speaking we've got
some fun things planned very
entertaining almost too much
entertainment yeah you and Rachel are
doing a little uh is it like a version
of your new podcast we're doing a live
interactive uh podcast does that mean
that you'll have the beverages the adult
beverage honestly they might be a
mocktail we don't know yet you know it's
early in the day Ken we can't go I have
a recommendation for you or Rachel
what's that
um my wife recently had a had a nice
beverage with some Elderberry in it oh
oh yes like a vodka base for the immune
system yeah a little Elderberry dropped
right in there and boy she thought it
was really refreshing I know you're not
taking suggestions but I thought I'd
give you a suggestion that's a good
winter time drink Ken thank you for that
so uh October 22nd we're all going to be
there it's a day-long and it's like
drinking from the fire hose Ken I mean
it is you're gonna leave exhausted but
also so motivated it's a lot of energy
whenever you put 6 000 people in a room
that are there for at least a common
goal of getting better uh and there's
just a lot of juice in the room you know
and it's a great event to bring friends
family who may not you know they may not
be in with the Ramsay gang yep and they
can get a taste of what we're all about
we've got a theme going here
you're too good I know it's happening so
go to ramseysolutions.com events get
your tickets today join us uh you don't
have much time and it's going to be a
great time I guarantee that we'd love to
see you there Dallas we're coming near
you soon coming to you soon not near you
actually coming to you we'll be in the
Heart of Dallas yeah there you go all
right yeah back to the phones we go
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Ethan joins us up next in Madison
Wisconsin Ethan welcome to the show
hi thanks how's it going doing great how
are you what's going on
good uh so I graduated in May of 2021
last year and uh over that course of
time I paid off twenty thousand dollars
in student loans I just took the first
job I could get out of school and
household and grinded and did that and
then I'd come to find out the student
loan forgiveness thing is happening
and I found that I'm eligible to apply
to like get my money back so to speak
I'd have to go back into debt with my
loan provider and then have my debt
forgiven that way
um how should I go about that should I
do that go back into debt in order to be
forgiven uh is that wise okay
all right I gotta jump in George Fair
quick uh because I read entirely too
much news every day there are now
multiple lawsuits that have been filed
by multiple States
against President Biden's executive
action this is not it's not me making
this up this is happening the reason is
is because you have a lot of privately
held student loans and so when he made
that executive action to say we're going
to pay off we're going to forgive ten
thousand it's affecting and again I'm
not I'm not defending it I'm just saying
it's real money that's that's that's
hurting private companies that hold
loans and people sign up for and then
the states are motivated to protect
those companies because those companies
are tax paying companies in their state
so I don't know if you're paying
attention to the news Ethan but that has
happened and so you have two things
going on so the lawsuits have been filed
so the ten thousand dollar forgiveness
is not happening until those lawsuits
are all dealt with number one number two
there there's they're they're not
actively moving towards those refunds
right now anyway so I I just want to put
that out there George because people
feel like this is a done deal I'm going
to go ahead and move forward with this
and it's the basis of his question so I
don't think it's going to happen yeah
and for those listening that aren't
clear on how this is working because
Ethan's going well they're going to put
me back into debt but it's forgiveness
so what we've been seeing is the student
loan companies are saying all right
we're gonna drop 10 grand back into your
bank account but we are also reinstating
your debt balance to ten thousand
dollars and now the hope is down the
line at some point the government comes
and wipes that 10 000 balance it makes
my head hurt only the government can
come up with something that's stupid
pretty convoluted but that's how it's
working right Ethan am I right on that
uh yeah that's what you described sounds
right to me so no don't do it so here's
what here's what some people are doing
I'm not going to advocate for against
this but what they're doing is saying
hey I'm gonna take that ten thousand
dollars in the bank and make sure not to
spend it which that takes a level of
discipline alone for people who had
already gone into debt uh thinking that
this was a good idea and then they're
saying I'm going to hang on to the 10
000 in case they don't forgive it and
I'll still have the money to pay it off
Ken oh sure that sounds wonderful so
Ethan that's kind of what you're
describing as a if you go through with
this that's what the hope is is that you
hang on to the 10 000 and once it's
forgiven you go all right cool this
money is free and clear now
gotcha gotcha so there's risk involved
is what we're saying and unnecessary
risk so don't do it
pay your student loans off the
government is not going to do it for you
and you're completely debt free now
yeah what baby step are you on now
um I was in four five and six but I just
replaced the transmission my car sent
back on three restocking that emergency
fund good man nice well you know what's
clear to me is that the secret sauce to
winning with money is Ethan and not a
third party not a government not a
forgiveness program and so I'm sticking
with the Ethan program for now and if
you so choose to do it I'm not mad at
you I'm happy for you for it to you know
Propel your financial Journey but
there's a lot of risk and a lot of
unknowns right now yeah certainly just
wait wait until the dust settles in the
form of all these lawsuits yeah I
appreciate the call
where's my little where's my little
thing you're just riling up Ken again
he's getting heartburn I want to hear
about the government and this this thing
it gets me right here we got the
tropical thumbs out back we'll get them
before you can on the break all right
blinds.com question of the day coming up
here they're 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you miss measure or you
pick the wrong color they will remake
your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code Ramsay to
get the best deal today's question comes
from Brittany in Illinois I work full
time at a large church and I love she
put in all caps my job but make forty
five thousand dollars a year I'm a
single mom homeowner and drive a modest
car even though I don't live
extravagantly I'm still living paycheck
to paycheck almost all my income is
going to tithe my mortgage bills and
income property taxes I used to make
fifty to a hundred dollars an hour as a
digital marketing copywriter but stopped
doing that when offered my current job
in Ministry with income is our biggest
wealth building tool but also living a
christ-centered life would you recommend
someone quitting the job in Ministry to
pursue a higher paying job my biggest
motivation to becoming financially free
is so that I can continue working in
Ministry without the stress of making
ends meet do I find a higher paying job
for a few years to get to baby step four
and then come back to Ministry uh that's
probably the direction but I want to go
back to some things that you know
you can desire to be in Ministry
but if you cannot in the ministry is
just like any other job
in that there's a pay range a scale
right for the type of job you do in
Ministry just like in industry
and even though you desire to work in
Ministry if you cannot if you're not
qualified and you aren't able to make
the amount of money that you need to
make
then what we need to do is go okay what
does Ministry look like
in another form in in other words you
can volunteer
you can work part-time in Ministry but
we've got to be able to sustain
ourselves and accomplish the financial
goals and I think if you can make 50 to
100 hours a digital marketing copywriter
but you stopped I'd get back into that
field to get the highest paying day job
possible now for the whole purpose of
getting the baby step four right and
getting your financial life stable to
where you can then go all right I could
take a bit of a pay cut but why not
maybe go back to a full-time day job do
some volunteer or part-time Ministry
work it's still valuable it is still
feeding that passion you have to
minister to others but it doesn't have
to be a full-time job that's okay too
yeah if you love your job but your
finances are so tight that you're so
stressed then you're not gonna have a
great life and there's more to it than
that so I want you to go back to that
marketing role maybe it's in a
Consulting part-time position but it
sounds like man you can Propel your
finances journey by jumping back into
that full time right now so it's a good
call Ken thanks for the question this is
the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell host of the fine print
and entree leadership podcast join this
hour by the host of the Ken Coleman Show
Ken Coleman you can find all of those
shows on the Ramsey Network or wherever
you listen to podcasts it's a free call
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life your money and your
career David joins us up next in
Virginia David welcome to the show
thank you how's it going
good how about you good good how can we
help today
yeah mine's more of a just a choice
question because I'm not sure but I'm
going to be able to background my wife
and I both come around 60. uh health is
so so that's one of our concerns is
always Healthcare of course
um we own a small business franchise at
this point in our lives we're debating
whether to
sell the franchise and go into another
franchise it maybe Isn't So labor
intensive or just go back to corporate
or we can get some decent health care
and write it out that way so we can just
take care of ourselves tell us a little
bit about the business itself what kind
of what kind of business is it and what
kind of money is it throwing off
uh commercial cleaning
um I've been doing 15 years
um revenues are about one seven
um so it's stable after a while what are
you paying yourself off the one seven
um I'm thinking 60 my life's taking 40.
wow where's the rest going
um most of it's being tucked away
because we're debt free
um we have a house is paid for said
that's grown and gone no College they
are tests you don't have a lot of
overall no is it just the two of you
just the two of you doing the cleaning
uh now we have a staff of about 30. oh
okay well that's where a lot of that
revenue is going too is payroll so when
you say labor intensive you don't mean
manual labor on your end you're just
saying the headache that it brings yeah
my my bot I I couldn't do it if I want
to do it my age but um how much have you
got saved for retirement
currently in our portfolio about 1.2
and what could you get for the business
if you sold it
uh we're getting evaluated right now but
we're guessing six
600 000 probably six hundred thousand
six hundred thousand on 1.7 in gross
revenue
that doesn't make sense it doesn't make
sense to me I've never heard it that way
but I do mean 1.7 million in gross
revenue per year correct correct a
million of that goes to Daryl
hmm that just seems awfully low I
thought you were saying 6 million which
sounded a lot closer
where'd you come up with that number
based on other franchises that are
similar that have been sold ah okay well
I got to tell you I'd sell it I'd get
out of that business there's just really
no long-term benefit for it the fact
that you're in your 60s you got health
issues uh the good news is you've got
great you know pretty good retirement
set up and you can continue to do so but
yeah I would cash out but I would not at
this age go into another franchise
that's just me I'm gonna go low risk no
risk is what we're saying I'm gonna go
no risk
and uh you guys have a lot to I feel
like your heart has left this business
and so I think it's time for your body
to do the same so I would cash out and
that will set you guys up nicely with
your nest egg and if you want to go
corporate to get some health care that's
not a bad idea but I don't want you to
do it just for the health care you do do
you guys have long-term care in place
we don't right now now and and for me
it's more of you know I still want to
work of course I still want to bring
some income in because we're not ready
to fully retire yet right but at the
same time I
I want to punch a clock and call it a
day and spend time with my wife and go
visit my daughter then do that that's
honorable
do it okay because we were you know the
decisions between being self-employed as
we are and continuing that route having
all those headaches that come with it or
just working with something has been
something my wife and I've played with a
lot yeah I just feel like we're hearing
a guy who doesn't want any more
headaches you just want to work for
somebody go do good do a good job and
leave work at work and go live your life
you just said as much
yeah I think you're right
well I mean you're the one that's saying
it it's not my opinion this is what I
heard and I I think in some way you're
you're calling us for permission and I'm
trying to Grant you permission to do
what it is we hear you say that you want
to do
yeah it's just so hard to look at it and
say you know you've been working for
yourself basically and there's a lot of
perks that come with that
um as opposed to you know reporting to
someone that's right so I want to make
sure we're set up to be able to retire
uh one day and you know just actually do
that at a decent age well I think you
are
George wouldn't you agree you're the
money guy I think he's set up now you're
only going to add to it if you sell the
company but let me let me just put it to
you this way working for yourself in
this current company do the perks
outweigh the headaches yes or no
financially that's the only side of it
right yeah so I'm going to ask it again
you just gave me a caveat do the perks
all of them do the perks outweigh the
headaches no no you tried to be a
politician on me on a Sunday Morning
Show the difference between me and those
Sunday morning host is I'm going to hold
you down it's not fooling around not
messing around
midterms are coming up you know
David listen you've done a good job man
I I I think what you want to do is the
right thing to do don't you George yeah
I think you to give you guys some peace
and Clarity I would connect with a
smartvester pro yes and run the numbers
because right now you're kind of hoping
and wishing not really sure what the
number is that you guys could actually
retire with
and I'm over here crunching some numbers
for you if you took that 600 Grand and
you just plopped it in an a taxable
brokerage account within seven six seven
years that'll be over a million on top
of your 1.2 and so you guys have to look
at your lifestyle and how much income
would we need to withdraw from our nest
egg every year to have a great
retirement do all the things you're
talking about David and that'll give you
some great clarity but you're in a great
spot how do you feel about what George
just threw at you
um it definitely puts a spark in it you
know without a doubt there we go George
you in that calculator I love a good
calculator you just inspired David you
just inspired it sometimes it just takes
a little math that's all it is but once
you have that David you guys are you've
worked so hard and you've lived unless
you make you're debt free you've been
doing this stuff and you got to remember
what the reason is yeah it's not just to
punch the clock
and David the numbers that George gave
you that doesn't even count you working
five or six more years that's if you
just put 600 Grand in and never touched
it and just put it in some good funds
and you never clean another corporate
office the rest of your life I wanted to
throw that in there how does that feel
there that works for me uh see we got
saved in a good mood Ken boy we did he's
chuckling I love it I like a good Chuck
I'm here for it yeah all right let's
take another one Megan joins us in
Kansas City Megan welcome to the show
hey thank you
um my question is my husband and I are
on on baby steps four or five six and my
question is outside of the 529 where
could we say for our children's future
do you feel like it's not enough in the
529
college and my family is a combination
of kids who
get their PHD law degree as well as kids
who cannot learn the traditional way
maybe an Associates at best but go more
the trade school certificates
um continuing
seminars that type of stuff and I kind
of just want
both my kids to be set up kind of
equally when they turn 18
bulk of it they're under two oh two kids
under two I thought you were gonna say
they're like 16. okay we got plenty of
time here you're just worried hey what
if they don't need the funds for
education
yeah what if they don't need the
financial education but I do want to
make sure and I say I my husband and I
do want to make sure that they are you
know set up to succeed but even if they
don't go to college they'll they'll they
will pursue some sort of Education right
yeah even if it's in the trades
uh yeah that's that's the goal and so
that money can be used towards any
expense when it comes to education it
doesn't have to be a four-year
University it can be towards housing and
laptops and all the things required to
do that and you can always change the
beneficiary
so if one kid needs more the other one
doesn't you can change the names and
move that money around
okay
so you're still just saying stick with
the 529
even if you want to make sure that they
are set up and they just go straight
into work yes because if they go
straight into work they don't need a
hundred thousand dollars sitting there
because they're going to have earned
income with no expense at that point
so there's not really anything to to
save for I mean they you can do
custodial IRAs and what's called an utma
uniform transfer to minors act there's
all kinds of things like that but I
wouldn't worry about that at this point
okay yeah you're doing great though at
two years old you're already thinking
about this most parents it's just oh my
gosh they're 18. I guess we need to oh
we're broke take out student loans we'll
co-sign and so the fact you're thinking
about this tells me they're gonna be
okay and the future of education is
probably only getting more expensive
again so I'd rather at least plan for
something and decide later thanks for
the call that puts this hour of the
Ramsay show in the books my thanks to
all the folks in the booth Jenna Ben
James Zach Andrew the whole gang and you
Ken Coleman thank you appreciate it
we'll be back with you before you know
it
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell joined by my colleague Mr Ken
Coleman this hour and we are here for
you to take your calls to give you that
next step to maybe help you have a
breakthrough and it's something you're
going through whether that's with your
money or your career so call us at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Griffin is kicking us off in
Charleston South Carolina Griffin
welcome to the show
hey guys thanks so much for having me my
dad and I are a huge fans so really
appreciate your time thank you
I want some guidance here on what to
tackle in terms of my loans or just to
keep stacking money in my savings
account
um currently have three main loans
between my town home student loans as
well as my car
um and to break down the numbers for you
the town home was just recently
purchased four hundred and ten thousand
dollars put down 10 and the current
loans for 368 535 that's not a seven
year arm at 4.75 I just paid my first
mortgage on the first of October and
that was 2 365 which I own the property
myself however I do split that payment
with my girlfriend that lives with me
okay and then we've got my student you
haven't got my student loans
um those to be perfectly honest with you
I have not paid in a while
um but there's about six different loans
between three point seven six percent
and four point six percent and the
standing balance on that is 26 654 and
then there's the car which is a three
point six ten percent loan
um and that total is nine thousand four
hundred and fifty five dollars and I'm
paying that every month obviously which
is a 341 payment okay what's your
question
my question is I've got income of about
175 000 a year 26 and I've been
fortunate enough to be put into this
position
um do I continue to do the minimum
payments on these loans or should I pay
my car off all in one month which
basically I'm a last commission check
that I just earned I can do that
um plus save some
um I'm trying to under to try to get
some guidance here on what next steps to
take to get to the point of Financial
Freedom really as quick as possible I
love it well one way to get to Financial
Freedom as quickly as possible is to
stop going into debt so are we on the
same page there's no more debt in the
picture
no more dead in the pastry I don't have
a credit card okay great so but all the
other things are debt
the car loan the student loan the town
home so here's one thing you mentioned a
lot of interest rates which tells me you
love math
you love crunching the numbers and
justifying every purchase right
yes sir so one thing we're going to do
it's really hard for people like you who
are sharp is to ignore the interest
rates
okay now if we ignore the interest rates
and we start listing these balances from
smallest to largest that tells me that
car loan is gone this month then we're
attacking the student loans those are
going to be gone in a few more months
right and then we're going to build an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses and then the house that'll come
later we're not going to worry about
that as part of our Consumer Debt
I should have mentioned I have 56 000 in
savings well that helps
we're debt free today my man what are
you waiting for
I should have mentioned that yeah so why
are you hanging on to the 56 and not
just paying off the debt as it's
accruing interest
because the well that's a great question
I think uh a large part of it is because
I want to stay for a town home I didn't
know how much exactly I needed until I
made the purchase which was just done in
the last three or four months so that
money is really residual from the money
I was saving up for a down payment so
you decided I'm just going to put 10
down and leave the rest in the bank
the difference between the 10 to 15 and
the offer that was provided it was
really not it wasn't it didn't make
enough sense for me to do the additional
five percent so I just put 10 down
that's correct and so this is you know
what like I just said just did my first
mortgage payment so kind of in one month
one of uh owning this property and
living it okay and trying to decide what
to do with my money yeah he's spinning
plates George she's got There's an
actual plates you're doing 17 things at
once number one it does worry me that
the girlfriend is paying into this and
she doesn't own any part of it and if
this doesn't work out she's gonna feel
like she got screwed right
um there you know I can't speak for
anybody here um but I what I do know is
that that did come to the situation by
salary alone would would pay and then my
commission on top right would would be
okay I would be able to pay these other
bills right so that that is I am in that
position I'll tell you what I would do
what Dave Ramsey would do if he was
sitting here and that is to be
completely debt free by the end of the
day and use the rest of the money as an
emergency fund and we're gonna then
start investing 15 of our income into
retirement any money beyond that is
going to get thrown at the mortgage and
I would probably look at refinancing
when it makes sense over to a 15-year
fixed rate because those adjustable rate
mortgages are the worst
okay very dangerous I appreciate it
so you're in a great spot we just have
to start doing things with Focus
intensity one at a time but the good
news is you can do this all tomorrow if
you decide to
okay so you know in terms of that's
exactly what I wanted to hear was I feel
like I'm putting a lot of attention
towards a few different things rather
than focusing and owning it as you know
gives a gazelle intensity as they would
say towards one of these exactly I mean
you know this stuff I'm just curious how
come you haven't done it it seems like
you've been listening for a while
um I I think a lot of it is uh I am
financially conservative and I like
being the bank account grow there's that
level of uh Pride but then the other the
other half of it is I am 26 and I I am
taking uh these steps a little quicker
than than maybe some people would but
you know there's no excuse for that I'm
I'm ready to tackle this at sir vacant
folks tomorrow so well your greatest
well-filling tool is your income you
make an amazing income at 26 of 175 000
and I just want to see it work for you
instead of it disappear into the abyss
and you're going I don't feel like I'm
making great progress uh I I'm listening
in here I'm listening intently Coach Ken
jump in I'm going to uh I I think you
have been tinkering because you like
finances
um I think you like strategies and
that's going to make you uh susceptible
and into Temptations to Tinker and so
here's my Coach Ken my Coach Ken phrase
stop tinkering
and start focusing focus on the baby
steps the way George laid them out
you've been listening to show just focus
on the baby steps stop tinkering around
you know what I mean just start you're
going to get further you're going to get
further with Focus right and uh and now
you you know you can always be curious
and see what options are for you long
term but that's after you get yourself
in a financially stable situation you
got it
yes sir absolutely
have you read The Total Money Makeover
Griffin
I haven't but I'm going to well can I
send it to you or do you already have a
copy
I don't have a copy but now you do boom
we're gonna ship it to you my man hang
on the line Austin will pick up and we
will send you a copy of The Total Money
Makeover that book gets me pumped every
time I still read it once a year just to
stay focused and stay motivated the
audiobook is great too so hang on the
line we'll get that to you but right now
focus is the operative word here and you
make a great income at a young age and
if you can use it and channel it like a
laser dude you can do some amazing
things with your money stop tinkering
start focusing I was hoping for a pretty
smart chalkboard I was really hoping on
a chalkboard right there all right I'll
take it Ken all right pretty good tweet
that this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hey folks here's your friendly reminder
that you can visit us here at the Ramsey
Solutions headquarters just south of
Nashville Tennessee we were just out
there meeting some nice folks taking
some pictures signing some books having
a good time so come visit us make it a
point on your uh your trips as you're
traveling around the country to come see
us we've got a free baked goods and free
coffee and you get a free mug and we've
got a fun timeline wall Museum and a
full bookstore and it is a good time
it's fantastic Nashville is a great City
to visit to begin with yeah yeah it's
you know years ago when I was hosting
the just the video channel
um had some folks come by and they asked
me to sign their baby
that's a true story uh so don't please
please don't bring your babies and ask
us to sign them like Sharpie on skin
Sharpie on the little guy's leg
I feel uncomfortable I didn't do it okay
oh good you didn't go through with it
yeah I just said they asked me to sign
well I redirected
don't make it weird people that's all we
gotta say there you go all right let's
go to the phones triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number to
call Grant joins us in Spokane
Washington Grant welcome to the show
thank you very much gentlemen I just
want to say thanks for accomplishing
your mission on a daily basis oh thank
you oh that's very nice thank you sir
what's going on all right
um baby step number three is where my
wife and I are at we've been married for
16 years we have five kids and legal
separation was proposed um she brought
it up the last night when we were
talking we have four thousand dollars to
the penny in our emergency fund right
now
and I think we've never established a
monthly budget that I think our nut to
cover is between three thousand and
thirty five hundred dollars just to
survive so we have essentially A month's
worth of savings right now my question
for you is
should I add a second job to go gazelle
intense to bump up our savings or is it
more important to deal with my mental
health
and my marriage
in this season
also one part of this is my mental
health I was diagnosed with bipolar a
number of years ago I think five years
ago and I was just on manic phase
yesterday oh my goodness are you seeing
someone or have you seen a counselor a
medical professional for this I I am
being treated by my team I have a
counselor that I see on a weekly basis I
have a psychiatrist where I assume I
think five or six times in the last
three months and they're actively
managing my meds and I just had a
medication change just today and we're
trying to find the right balance for the
different mood stabilizers and the
different medications that they have
been on so on six or seven different
medications in the last four years I
mean do you and the team feel like
there's progress that has been made and
that it's at least while we're still
testing and trying that there's some
progress I think I think we're testing
and trying I know that in September I
was I was hospitalized twice one was
voluntary the other one was involuntary
and it's been it's been a hard life for
my wife just dealing with my moods yeah
and uh she she's receiving counseling
for herself individually over the last
year and
she's not willing to go back to the
relationship that we used to have just
because it was unhealthy it's an
unhealthy Dynamic where she was trying
to regulate my moods with behaviors that
she would that she no I I don't know
yeah I don't want to crass but she would
try and control me with sex by giving me
what I wanted and it was just goes
unhealthy yeah well so to answer your
question you need to be focusing on your
health and her health yes sir and want
to see you get you know that emergency
fund where it needs to be but we we've
got bigger issues at play right now yeah
I mean a situation like this if it's
heading towards divorce it turns
marriage into a business transaction and
so the goal at that point is to
obviously protect the kids that's the A1
and number two is to make this as little
of a mess as possible with the finances
and so how sure is this separation is
this something you guys are going to try
to work through or is this is this
headed south
well even legally or we've been
separated since November 10th of last
year so it's 11 months in
and it doesn't seem to make we haven't
seen much forward progress we've done
intensive marriage counseling weekend
and week out for the last 12 weeks and
it was financially costing us 150 a
second and somebody at our chairs
established a bit of a fund for the
Higgins family
for us to receive 50 of that counseling
to cover when we were coming out of
pocket 75 a week and
it was a financial no it was a pretty
good Financial ask on our on our part
but we were we didn't I can't I can't
look back and say that we've made
progress in the last few months I can
say that times are gone we spent the
money but we haven't really made
progress and then you had the
conversation last night where she she
brought up let's we need to make this
legal
yes sir so it doesn't look good and and
no and so at this point again the
emergency fund but but you taking a
second job if you've got the health to
do so I don't think that's a
I I don't I don't know if it's a good
thing or a bad thing but bringing in
more income during this season uh might
be a right idea but I certainly would
check with your your uh
your medical team uh on this to see you
know do they feel like this is you know
adding more at work hours during this
transition is that healthy for you I I
ca we can't speak to that it feels like
it may not be yeah I mean you you guys
don't have debt and if this does head to
divorce then you know being married with
16 years five kids then it becomes who's
getting what and custody battles and all
that stuff and so I would I would be
looking at getting a lawyer to figure
this out if it's been 12 months with no
progress yeah
in five weeks it'll be 12 months so
we're not we're not on the 12-month Mark
yet but we're almost to the 11 month
Mark so it's like it's
but at that point I might look at
getting separate checking accounts
because the fear is one spouse drains
the account and runs and you don't have
any recourse
if things continue to go south it sounds
like it's been amicable which is great
and everyone's you know we're still
living you're living as roommates
essentially right for the last almost a
year we're we're not in the same
household okay I have them we're
physically we're about three miles apart
where are the kids
with her well all four and then the
fifth one our second born as a municipal
relationship with her she's 11 years old
and she's living with her aunts okay I'm
just wondering what what's best long
term for the kids at this point what's
fair to them and living in this weird
Purgatory of our mom and dad together
not it's not official they're still
trying to work through this I'm just
more worried about the kids than
anything at this point and so I would
try to actually have some level of
closure to whatever this is it sounds
like we need to just call it if you've
been living apart for this long
I don't want to give up on it though
well I'm with you brother I I would so
back to the main point of your question
I mean if you've got to work and if you
can do it and and you've got to work to
to help pay for the counseling I'd fight
for the marriage I'd fight for I I will
tell you this just candidly
uh one of my closest friends in the
world went through a divorce over a
decade ago and we were recently hanging
out and and it was an amicable divorce
um but we were talking about another
friend of ours who's going through a
divorce right now and he told me my
friend that's been divorced now over a
decade he said I would tell him to fight
with every ounce in his body with
everything he's got left fight
to save the marriage because it is so
destructive to the kids to everybody so
I I'm with you man I'd summon every
ounce of strength I've got and and I
would put some of that strength into you
doing everything you can
to get healthy because a healthy you is
the best chance we have of having a
healthy marriage
but I'd fight I think
I'm I hear what you're saying and I want
to fight and
I one thing that specifically that she
said in the last week is that she wants
me to sign the program to follow through
on the program and not to Short Circuit
the program and
yeah just the follow through and the
consistency is what I need to show
different they do it kill myself they do
it okay do it you can decide
you can decide right now do it show her
if you're gonna fight and you want to
fight then I'd say all right babe I'm
gonna do it and I'm gonna follow through
and show you that I want our marriage to
work hang on the line Grant we're going
to send you a copy of Dr John deloney's
book own your past change your future so
we can continue to walk with you through
this really tough situation thanks for
the call this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more first
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by my
friend Ken Coleman and Ken you were just
on your own show right before this one
the kid Pullman show helping folks find
those careers that they love and a lot
of people don't believe it's possible
they're not sure how to get there it's
all very squishy and you walk them
through a very clear process in those
calls yeah we do and you know it's as
simple as self-awareness you know an
aware person is very clear then on who
they are what they want to do why they
want to do it and then that translates
the confidence to step out and go after
it and then it gives you ultimately
courage to stay on the path we've got a
great tool that we develop based on that
methodology the methodology is simple if
you use what you do best talent to do
work that you really love that's passion
to produce results that you care deeply
about that's a sense of mission when you
use talent to perform passion to produce
your mission you're on purpose when
we've got a great assessment of tens of
thousands of people have downloaded it's
called the get clear assessment I've got
a printout right here this is what you
can actually print out you have the
digital version as well I'm looking at
mine right now but you get a very nice
detailed report on
what you do best what work really fires
you up and then what results drive you
in other words motivate you it's called
the get clear assessment and it's
normally thirty dollars it's a 20 minute
assessment and you get a detailed report
plus a a a very clear purpose statement
that's filled in with those top three
talents top three passions and that
primary motivational driver that we call
Mission and it's now ten dollars at
ramseysolutions.com there's no
assessment like it there's there there's
other assessments that measure talent
but nothing that measures what you love
and then what motivates you and so
you've got to understand Talent is a
tool but it is Passion which is love and
then Mission which is what motivates me
that's the heart
so 20 minute assessment it's a great
gift it is great for a variety of people
people who feel stuck people who feel
like they've got no clue what they want
to do people who have a really good idea
and they want to get some clarity and
confidence that that is in fact the
amount they want to climb so to get
clear assessment it's only ten dollars
in the month of October right now at
ramseysolutions.com that's a killer deal
I've taken it myself and I'm looking at
it right now and it was spot on it was
like you were reading my mail Ken see
there it is it says you were created to
use your talents of imagination
communication and discernment to perform
your passions of promoting leading and
creating to accomplish your mission of
creation by producing new things and
ideas I couldn't have said it better
myself so that becomes a high level job
description and so you want to be able
to spend 75 percent of your day living
that purpose statement out and you are
my friend I love to create it's a lot of
fun and it gives you possible Industries
based on your results and look at this
it's got education and motivational
speaking and writing it's got everything
I'm doing Ken so I feel like I'm in my
sweet spot well you confirmed it you are
and not only you're in your sweet spot
you look fantastic in your little bomber
jacket it's a little bomber well it is
you're a little guy and to be fair it is
an extra small you wouldn't want to wear
a big bomber jacket that's true yeah
well uh before we can digs me any
further I'm going to mention that you
can go get that uh get clear assessment
for just 10 bucks at ramseysolutions.com
hurry up it won't last long so thank you
well actually it'll last forever you
know why it's a digital we never run out
that's true
well unless the internet and by the way
you don't have to pay shipping or
handling you know why it's digital it's
digital thank you for the my mom
listening she'll be like oh that's
helpful Ken thank you that's great
that's that's my Democrat she's always
listening all right let's go to the
phones if you've got questions about how
to advance in your career switch careers
side hustles increase that income Ken is
here for you and I can help jump in on
those money questions the number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Andrew is jumping in next in
Cincinnati Ohio Andrew welcome to the
show
oh hello hey hey
how you doing this is awesome can you
hear me okay yeah Andrew you're live on
the Ramsay show how can we help oh dude
sweet anyway so this is a kind of a
student loan question there's layers of
this so if I you if you ask me questions
if you feel like I need to clarify right
so
um in the end I don't know oh about
thirty nine thousand dollars in student
loans
um so 12 000 of that is to my parents
and then there's about three or like
four or five of them that are just
federal student loans
um my my father decided it was like a
parent plus one and he decided that he
wanted to pay off the loan
um about two or three years ago
and now he um I'm in a situation with
work when I'm earning a lot more money
than I used to and I won't be able to
pay off these loans a lot faster and
then went on top of Biden doing the ten
thousand dollars you know and if I was
going to go ahead and I'll take it to
the basket you know what I'm saying so I
am um
that was a sports reference yeah we just
went to SportsCenter there I want to
address that in a minute but keep going
what's your question
so the question is is so my dad wanted
went ahead and paid off that student one
and now that I'm in the situation of
work when I'm making a lot more money
um he he was telling me that he he wants
that money back right rightfully so and
so I'm stuck in between this should I go
ahead and do the
um the baby steps for the student loans
or should I go ahead and pay off my dad
first which is the biggest one and get
rid of that slave master relationship
um
that's interesting so you're saying hey
should I do the debt snowball as is even
though the 12 000 is at the very end of
it but Dad's hanging over my neck going
hey I want this money back how much does
he need this money versus it just being
a moral hey I paid this off but it was
for you I'd like the money back
is he in a tough Financial spot
no he's he's not he honestly he's he's
told me that dude it could be like two
three four years like it's fine
um so he's like this is not like every
time he's on the phone he's like Hey
where's my loan money at no no no no no
no nothing like that but then this goes
back to the work part of things is that
I'm in this situation where I'm able to
pay off a lot more money within the next
like 18 weeks but the money's not going
to last forever so it's either pay off
the Federal loans and just like
they just do the dead snowball just
smallest to largest and you'll get there
a lot faster and then when you get to
the end time to pay dad back and you're
done with this whole thing within what a
year
well so no so Vegas it is where things
get a little confusing is that I so I'm
a respiratory therapist shout out red
story therapist
um and because of um coven and all that
stuff they're really desperate for
nurses and respiratory therapists and
doctors in all Healthcare World
um and so they're paying me an extra
about 60 an hour which would be about
ninety dollars an hour
um which makes a lot of disposable
income after this
um but after all this is done and
they're like all right gravy trains over
get off you know like I only have about
three four hundred dollars left of to go
towards debt and that's what I'm saying
that's fourteen thousand dollars is is
going to be there for a long time
so how long will it take to pay off your
debt making this extra money you're
making right now thirty nine thousand
how quickly can you pay that off
making this
if you're in Texas so
let's see
so I'll be honest I haven't really
looked at yeah yeah can I can I jump in
Hey listen bro let me let me help you
out there's nothing confusing about what
you threw at us nothing I kept waiting
for the confusing part the only thing
that's confused
it's not layers you'd use the debt
snowball make an extra income right
there's a season in your in your work
life where you you got a boon of income
I mean it's it's it's it's kind of
booming for a while yes you attack it
faster right but it's not like as a
respiratory therapist you're not going
to have an opportunity to make more
money elsewhere
um and and and you're acting like you
know the income's gonna go away and
you'll never be able to get a raise or
move up I mean you're thinking too hard
you stop you just work the snowball work
the debt snowball smallest to largest
intense second job third job whatever
you got to do gazelle intense whatever
that looks like for you to pay every
loan back including your debt and
honestly you'll get there I think a lot
quicker than you realize this is not an
in insurmountable amount of debt and you
can do this it's not going to be there
forever and and you just have to stop
thinking so much and get busy how much
money do you have in the bank right now
Andrew
[Music]
um we're going on about about seven
thousand okay we're taking six of that
just throw it this debt we're gonna take
this amazing income you have to clean up
the rest we're paying dad back and all
of a sudden 12 months from now no
excuses you're completely dead free with
a fully funded emergency fund it's that
simple no layers George this was not
that this was not a Tiramisu cat it was
not that complicated not that many
layers for you man just don't overthink
it you got this one thing at a time
Focus intensity and you'll be debt free
in no time this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I'm George Campbell he's Ken Coleman
this is the Ramsay show you can give us
a call at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Brian is joining us
from Houston Texas Brian welcome to the
show
all right thank you guys for having me
absolutely what's going on
all right so
um I've been 27 years old my wife is 25
and we have a three week old at home
and
um my based my question is are we doing
baby step four correctly
um we've been on the Ramsey plan for a
little over a year now and this is my
current situation I contribute six
percent to my company's 401k and they
match 50 of that to reach the other nine
percent my wife and I are planning on
opening up a Roth IRA for each of us my
wife was a teacher for two years and has
nine thousand dollars in her teacher
retirement account called TRS we plan on
rolling that over to a rock and paying
the taxes then to open up a Roth for me
we have to have six thousand dollars to
start the account
does it make sense to open up my account
before year ends 2022 so we can
contribute monthly up to six thousand
dollars in 2023 to meet our nine percent
hmm
well you wouldn't roll into a Roth and
create a tax burden until you're in baby
step seven with a paid for house
and so I would roll that to a
traditional IRA in order to avoid taxes
okay on on my wife's portion yes
and that's just so that we're in control
and you can still invest in that
traditional IRA or you can then open up
a new Roth IRA and use future funds
towards that and that wouldn't create a
tax burden
okay so you would use after tax dollars
uh is she so she's not working outside
the home right now is she with the three
week old
yes so she's so she's not teaching
anymore she's going to stay at home with
the baby okay and what's your income
gross
um my current is uh 69 000 but with uh
bonuses the bonuses are pretty generous
it's usually between an extra six and
fifty thousand a year six and fifty
yeah it's a pretty I'm in the oil and
gas so when Times Are Good Times Are
Good
yes sir okay so the easiest thing to do
with that kind of a regular income with
bonuses just invest 15 of your income uh
whatever it is that month and so you can
do that you said six percent uh is what
you're doing now and they match 50 is it
up to a certain amount they match or
they match all the way
um so that up to that six percent so
they put in I guess three percent of my
income you could say okay so that six
percent gets you up to the match then
you could fully fund a Roth IRA
Q that's another six thousand
okay
and then does she have earned income at
that point
no no she's she's staying at home okay
so you could go back to the 401K
as well as funding a traditional order
Roth so you would open up a new Roth for
her at that point we just don't want to
roll the traditional plan she had into a
Roth because that is when the tax burden
would hit it'll just be taxable income
so I would open up a new Roth for her
what's that
I see what you're saying so the nine
just to a traditional and then open up a
new rock for her exactly
and you should have a 6 000 Inlet on
that for the year
okay and when we open up a rock for me
yes
and then if they're still you haven't
hit 15 you can go back to that 401k and
finish it out there
okay I see I see what you're saying yeah
I was I was curious because I I figured
I would probably open it up for me this
year at that 6 000 so that I can
contribute to it next year because if I
start it at least this is like my
financial I I talked to uh one of the
smart Buster pros and he said well if
you start it at the 6000 in January you
can't contribute to it all year
yeah it might be something you have to
just start later on then
if you can't do it retroactively
so yeah I think you've got it down man
you guys are doing great and congrats on
the three week old that's exciting yeah
get some sleep
I'm surprised you're this sharp with a
three week old yeah I think you're
extremely coherent my friend that's uh
that's a tough season impressed yeah but
I love it
I think I cut them off George I'm sorry
Brian are you still with us did I cut
you off buddy
yeah I'm sorry I was saying I'm married
to an amazing woman who's been married a
nerd so I wanted to hear that he married
an amazing woman who married a nerd but
you know what could you say the same
thing about you and your situation my
situation you know both of our wives
have horrible judgment and thus we are
married fool them yeah we do love it
yeah all right we're going to the great
city of Scranton Pennsylvania up next
with our friend John John what's going
on
call uh I have I sold my silver route of
3500 that was paid off and then I paid
in cash for a Peterbilt
and I want to know if it's okay while
I'm babysit two to save up a repair fund
for the Peterbilt of 50 Grand
why do you eat 50 grand for that
the uh Peterbilt is new to me it has 835
000 miles and caterpillars the engine
recommends a engine overhaul at a
million miles
engine overhaul according to Peterbilt
costs uh thirty two thousand dollars
so is this rig is this for your business
yep just started it okay and it's paid
for
yes but you now have a fifty thousand
dollar repair on this thing
uh potentially right now it runs fine
but uh adding another 150 000 miles to
it it's probably gonna happen in four or
five months okay and how much debt do
you have
I have 72 000. and what is that
uh 68
000 on solar panels oh and then four
thousand remaining on a personal loan
that I'm almost done with
okay what's the business
and you sold the the the Chevy Silverado
to buy the Peterbilt to haul the water
yes you were hauling it in the Silverado
before
no I I'm I was working for a different
uh uh a different company hauling it in
a Kenworth for another person and I
decided to go owner operator so I sold
my paid in full Silverado do you have
another car for personal use
yes and that's paid for as well how much
water are we dragging around
130 barrels
have you made money with this business
yet is it profitable
uh I start on the 17th
okay and it's just you or do you have a
team
it's just me right now
okay and your first gig is on the 17th
yes is there another way sorry for the
simplistic question but I'm going
somewhere with this is there another way
to drag the water around then then the
old truck
and I mean like a wagon or something
forgive me but there's some sort of a
trailer that's a whole lot less money
and doesn't have all the mechanical
issues
uh
yeah thanks for the question uh the
Frack companies take at a minimum 110
barrels at a time
is there a seventy thousand pounds so no
a Silverado it's something smaller
cannot do it okay if you can't pull it
in a trailer
no no it's uh way overweight okay I got
you all right forgive me I I don't know
anything about that stuff at all okay so
your your question is Cash flowing this
during baby step two
yeah saving it up for repairs on Parts
should he save up the emergency fund and
this would be like saving reserves for
your business at that point yes sir and
so if this is an emergency where the
truck won't run right now then yes and
you know it's going to happen but I
would get some clarity on when it's
going to happen and how much that's
going to cost and then kind of create
that sinking fund and if that's ten
thousand twenty thousand a month I don't
know how much this business is going to
bring in do you have any idea
I should have the 50 Grand in uh within
10 weeks oh wonderful I tell you what
I'd also be looking to find the best
most affordable reputable mechanic that
works on these things and get in a
second opinion as well and what can you
do along the way maybe to try to avoid
uh the uh recommended engine replacement
at million miles I'd be doing everything
I could to save from preventative
maintenance as well yeah but I would
you're gonna have to stockpile that kind
of cash in your reserves for your
business on top of then starting to
clean up the debt and create your own
emergency fund for your personal life
and so that's part of being a small
business owner but uh I wish you the
best with this new business man that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to Ken Coleman all the
folks in the booth Jenna Ben James
Austin Zach Andrew the whole gang and
new America thanks for listening we'll
be back with you before you know
foreign
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsay personality George
Campbell join this hour bye my friend
Ken Coleman and we are here for you to
take your call to give you some hope and
all kinds of areas of life maybe it's
money maybe it's your career a toxic
work situation a bad debt situation we
want to help the number to call is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five John kicks us off in Pensacola John
welcome to the show
uh hey how are y'all doing we are doing
great what's going on with you
uh well I was working for a previous
employer uh for approximately four to
five months they gave me a pretty good
um starting starting bonus package and I
worked there for a while but it wasn't a
great work environment I didn't really
enjoy it and I thought I'd be better at
my previous job so I decided to leave I
understood I was gonna have to pay back
my starting uh package which I you know
I was more than willing to do but
they've kind of tacked on a whole lot of
other fees which I feel are really
exorbitant and now I'm kind of stuck
paying back my previous employer with
way more than what they gave me in the
starting bonus package was this all in
writing what you would have to pay back
I did have to sign a contract standard I
would have to pay back uh you know some
of the moving fees and stuff like that
at the very beginning but it was way way
more than what I thought it was going to
be okay but what I'm getting at is is is
it laid out very clearly in that
agreement
to where what they're asking you to pay
back is clearly by the letter of the
agreement okay not included or is it
just it's included uh but you just
thought it would be less money that's
what I'm trying to get to
I gotcha and the original agreement it
really just kind of said to try to pay
back the money that we gave you plus the
moving expenses and uh things of that
nature it doesn't really give out a
outlined amount or anything like that
okay so so the expenses that they are
now wanting you to pay back they fall
within the categories written very
clearly in the agreement
uh
I would say yes but they're they're way
way more they're like almost twice as
much
okay is it listed out so you have
receipts of what you actually so my
point is you have Financial records to
be able to dispute that what they're
asking is more than they actually paid
you
um yeah kind of so I guess I'll put it
this way like so uh they gave me a
starting point I'll give you the numbers
if you don't mind sure yeah they gave me
a starting bonus of like sixteen
thousand dollars and I was like okay
cool and they moved me from North
Alabama down to Florida where I am now
um and you know I left the company like
I said after about five months and now
they're trying to say I can pay them
back 34 000 and I was you know kind of
flabbergasted at that number I thought I
was going to pay back maybe 16 plus
moving costs of like maybe maybe twenty
thousand dollars all together but
they're talking about thirty five
thousand dollars what was the signing
bonus
yeah
16k and then the relocation costs
the relocation cost is what I think is
kind of kind of crazy there because I'm
looking at the numbers now they're
saying that it costs um
about seven thousand dollars to move
from from North Alabama down to Florida
in Pensacola Florida which is not even
down to the Panhandle near Miami it's
close to uh you know it's close to
Alabama
yes so did they pay you seven thousand
dollars does that end up in your bank
account no sir that was just how much
they say it cost to move that far
well they so they paid it directly with
the moving company
correct
I uh having moved you know from
Georgia to Tennessee I don't that
doesn't sound crazy it doesn't sound
like it's off much
um but again you need to be asking for
receipts so the 16 and the signing bonus
the seven in relocation where's the rest
of this 34 coming from
yeah and the rest of it they got I'm
looking at the thing here they they uh
they had me in temporary lodging for a
little while before I found a an
apartment down here okay that uh
the temporary lodging was five thousand
dollars for just one month and
and uh let me see here I mean that
sounds fair for temporary if that's you
know corporate rents or Corporate
Lodging is more expensive than a
traditional rent
yeah but it's 166 bucks a night okay
I just stayed in the basic Hotel you
know so I was just yeah I mean you got
to ask them you got to ask them to show
you all the receipts of this stuff if
they will I mean if you're gonna dispute
it you you got to have some facts
I gotcha yeah what was the agreement was
if you stayed a certain amount of time
you don't have to pay it back exactly
and it was like I want to say two years
or one I can't remember if it was one or
two years but it's going over two years
yeah it sounds like
there you didn't do your due diligence
and homework and reading all the fine
print and figuring it out and they're
covering all these expenses and it's not
up to you to do the research and make
sure that it's affordable you were just
kind of like all right they're covering
the costs
um but at the same time you sign an
agreement saying if you leave under
those two years you owe us all the money
back yeah so it stinks it I would put
this under I would file it under stupid
tax
and it may be one of those money
mistakes where you go man that sucked I
have to pay that back I mean you can try
to fight it and do civil lawsuit I just
don't think you have much of a much
ground to stand on if they've got all
their receipts which I assume they do
I yeah I gotcha I actually did hire uh a
lawyer to see if they can kind of
dispute this for like a thousand dollar
retainer and he's trying to help me out
here uh but you know I don't know if I
can get the mail much lower you might be
able to settle with them and pay a
smaller amount
that's probably best case scenario
yeah because I'm willing to pay the of
course at 16 and I'm in something else
of course on top of that but I just
didn't want to pay the full 30 34. uh to
be honest with you I agree with George I
would propose a settlement you know but
uh based on the numbers that you've
given us so far it doesn't sound like
you're getting gouged sounds like
they're they're listing out every single
expense and they probably have receipts
because they're a legitimate company and
so at that point there's not much to
fight
um yeah I agree you guys are
oh I mean it sucks I'm not trying to
belittle that this really is not a fun
situation
um and I'm rooting for John but at this
point it's one of those dang it should
have read that fine print should have
asked more questions should have asked
them where they're lodging me because I
don't know if this is going to work out
over there but it sounds like to me they
gave you a detailed printout or they
gave you a detailed layout of the 34
000. it all equals up to thirty four
thousand correct
yeah that's correct I'm looking at it
now yep man I I mean that's what I'd be
asking for and you got it so you know uh
unless you can somehow prove that
they're price gouging it kind of feels
like a medical bill where like you don't
know what the procedure is costing and
what insurance is and then all of a
sudden you're like oh my gosh yeah I'll
have a 34 000 medical bill yeah that's
about what it feels like too and that's
kind of why I'm looking at you because
I've personally moved across the country
before and and it cost me 2500 with all
my stuff to move that's John doing at
John's way with John's research and John
choosing the company this is a company
who is flushed with cash it's probably
also some movers that are wearing weight
belts instead of proper back support
they rented a truck that study I mean
2500 to move across country that might
have been 30 years ago oh yeah boy oh
boy it's expensive to move these days
John that stinks and for those listening
who are entering into a situation like
that do your due diligence and think
about what if this doesn't go to plan
maybe I should have this money set aside
until those two years are over in case
this thing goes south and that just puts
you in a better Financial spot than
where we find our friend John by the way
that's why you should also be using PODS
moving in storage Great
calls they're not gonna they're not
gonna cost you an arm at all I'm gonna
do you dirty they're gonna take that's a
saying Ken is it I gotta teach Kenzie
lingo I'm sorry hey more of that lingo
coming up right here on the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
folks the stock market has been rough
lately and if you've been watching your
Investments take a hit it sucks I get it
but if you're freaking out don't Market
dips don't mean you have to retire broke
you've got to keep a long-term
perspective and remember that investing
is a marathon not a Sprint so look at
the facts if you invest 120 dollars a
month from age 25 to 65 you could have
over a million dollars for retirement no
it's not too good to be true that's
based on the long-term average return of
the S P 500 which is the top 500
American companies now if you're not 25
you're a little older than that that's
okay it's not too late you got to get
started though no matter what age you
start investing you'll be happy you did
when it's time to retire in fact a huge
predictor of investing success is that
you actually invest shocker I know and
you keep investing consistently so get a
pro in your corner to help you get
started to find one who can help you
invest with confidence just go to
ramsaysolutions.com smartvestor and
we'll connect you with smartvestor Pros
in your area who can help help you make
a plan for your goals and guide you
through the ups and downs of the market
again ramseysolutions.com smartvestor
Jack joins us up next in Montana Jack
welcome to the show
thank you thank you what's going on
taking my call well I inherited ninety
five thousand dollars
um 58 years old my life is 63.
um we bought a house
and I want to get it paid off
um we oh we bought it for 280
um we owe 195.
um we have thirty six thousand five
hundred and ninety five dollars and
sixty cents in the bank that's not
towards your bills we have no credit
card debt we haven't had any debt three
years
um I'll I'll go back to my story on so
you can get a little just 17 years ago
or actually 20 years ago I got divorced
at fifty thousand dollars in debt
um focused on that and now I'm sitting
with the money in the bank
280 000 in a 401k
um and I the only debt I have is the 195
000 on the house cool my question is is
I would like to take that 95 000 and
just put it down on my house and that
gets me down to a hundred thousand with
what we've been doing our house will be
paid off in five years
um without a doubt
um I got other people saying no don't do
that because I'll have to pay twelve
thousand dollars in taxes if I take that
money out for income taxes if you take
one right now if you take the inherited
money yeah you inherited yes I take that
in here inherited money I'm gonna have
to pay income tax I'm not going to hurt
everybody okay um which is roughly about
twelve thousand dollars so I'm thinking
um other people are saying and I talked
to a financial advisor I can invest it
on a 13 13 month CD or whatever at like
four percent interest of course a
financial advisor is going to want you
to invest it instead of paying your
house down so that's not a reputable
Source in that regard I'm paying the
taxes on it I'm putting it on the house
and puts you closer to what 112 on the
mortgage yeah yeah and let's still make
it a goal to pay it off in five years
and that money in the bank that you have
is that your emergency fund with a
little more yeah yeah a little more and
and we drive that's the other thing is
we drive old cars I haven't bought a car
um but we can't water can't we don't go
out of town much if I do go on a trip I
just rent a car I figure it's smarter
than having that payment every month if
you borrowed money I could take the 36
000 and we thought about this because my
wife is 63 like I said I'm 58 with the
car prices today we do need a new car so
when we retire we will have a vehicle
and we've thought about taking twenty
thousand dollars of that thirty six
thousand dollars and buying a car that
we can rely on what's your household
income
uh what is it I got it written down here
um 95 000. okay
great my wife is retired that's 95 000
before I put 15 in a 401k we put 250 in
this evening you know we keep adding to
that money okay um so I would I would
separate your emergency fund so separate
your emergency fund have your three to
six months and then have a different
savings account for your car upgrade and
buy a reasonable used car with cash and
I'm paying this house down and I'm gonna
make that a goal because it's going to
be hard to retire with a mortgage
hanging over your head and you've got
280 in your 401k you're gonna need more
than that to live on and so at least
without a house payment you can limit
your expenses and so you have you don't
need much to live on in retirement so
that's that's what I would do if I was
in your shoes and I would ignore those
other people because other people are
broke and everyone's got an opinion but
this is your money in your life and
having no mortgage payment changes
everything so appreciate the call
all right up next we are going to
Charlotte North Carolina Brandon joins
us there Brandon welcome to the show
hey thanks for having me guys sure
what's going on uh yeah so I just we
just moved to North Carolina actually
and we are in the process of trying to
figure out what Auto Insurance
to use and I'm just not super familiar
should we do full coverage uh liability
obviously there's tons even in within
that so I would love to see some of your
thoughts on auto coverage yeah I mean
you definitely want liability you're
going to want comprehensive and you're
going to want collision and uninsured
motorist is very important too
that one can tank some people
and a really easy way to do this what's
that
I said I worked with one of your um elps
and they had just kind of given me two
quotes one with full coverage and one
with limited liability and I was like I
don't know which one to pick so yeah I
mean I would go with the full coverage
because these situations can put people
in a real pickle when they are
underinsured and I've been there uh this
was about I don't know eight nine years
ago I got in a car wreck and I didn't
have great coverage I was still on my
parents insurance and I was underinsured
and we ended up getting sued and luckily
I didn't have to pay anything out of
pocket but this was three years of
nightmares hanging over my head going am
I gonna have to you know go out of
pocket for this and she ended up getting
50 Grand between the two insurance
companies her own and mine and so that
was a scary moment and from then on I
made sure that I had as much coverage as
I could get that made sense for me
so did they walk you through the options
of what it looks like to have full
coverage versus limited liability
not really he just kind of sent the two
I mean it's broken down in terms of what
it covers and how much and those kinds
of things but we never really talked
about it he just sent it over so I
wasn't sure because I was like man we
drive to hoopties if you will and um
well my wife's car is less of a hoopy
but it's like the cars aren't worth that
much so it's really about just other
people's medical then versus replacing
your car
yeah yeah
um
yeah well I mean when you have limited
liability collision and comprehensive
that's what full coverage is and I would
recommend all three so if you can swing
it can you can you cover the expense
what's the difference between them yeah
uh we're talking like 117 versus like 71
so it's not like a huge difference we're
just we're really getting up in the pace
of going like both of us getting on the
same page and feeling like I don't know
it just was like a small thing that I
was just like uh but that's like an
extra 40 bucks I can go somewhere kind
of thing yeah
well in this process we're gonna we're
starting uh starting a company uh we're
starting business and so that's been fun
and but you know there's just expenses
there so I feel like we're cutting in
all these spots so I just went there you
don't want to cut there 540 I got a
subscription then cutting into my uh
Insurance that's right so if you can get
a good rate on full coverage I'm going
for it and that sounds very reasonable
sweet okay so and you can get a second
opinion on that but I've got full
coverage and I sleep better at night and
that's worth the extra you know 20 30
bucks
and you don't sleep well as it is right
terrible sleep issues but one thing I
don't worry about is insurance and there
are so many types of Insurance Ken I
know you your brain just melts a little
bit having to talk about insurance for
too long here we go with people with the
types of crazy Insurance stores you love
this and actually I love it too because
it's quite entertaining it's like a it
could have been a top 10 list on
Letterman yeah we covered what do we got
I did a tick tock on this cat there was
something about aliens there was alien
abduction Insurance alien abduction
Insurance my personal favorite my
favorite is the the pet Rapture
Insurance where atheists will take care
of your pets if you die and you're a
Christian and you get raptured The
Atheist said hey for the low price of 10
bucks a month I'll make sure Fido's
covered it's this kind of crap that
makes Christians look and look bad
that's that's just ridiculous well Ken I
did a five day video series that's
completely free to help folks get more
confidence in their coverage you can go
sign up for that at ramseysolutions.com
confidence you'll get an email every day
with a quick three minute video and by
the end you're gonna be a pro even Ken
can do this stuff no thanks to you yeah
I'm here for you Ken and don't buy alien
abduction insurance no we don't
recommend that goes down we got bigger
problems all right more of your calls
coming up on the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ramsay personality George Campbell Ken
Coleman co-hosting today this is your
show America give us a call Triple eight
eight two five five two two five Laura
joins us up next in Knoxville Tennessee
Laura welcome to the show
hi guys thanks for
absolutely how can we help today
um
passed away
um in December of last year
I took a little bit of time off from
work thank you I took a little time off
from work
um after that
um and I returned to work but at reduced
hours so well I had been working a
regular 40-hour week I'm now working a
32-hour week so of course my
annual salary is adjusted
um yeah for that
um and I'm just curious if that's
something that I can afford to do long
term
um you know planning for the future now
is is quite a bit different than it was
this time last year so I'm a little
stumped on on how to proceed from here
sure well we can walk through some of
these numbers and give you some peace
about that but I just want to say I'm so
sorry yes for your loss how old was he
uh he was 47 and I'm 41. oh my God much
too young
yeah
well let's walk through some of these
numbers so what are you making right now
with that 32 hours a week
uh right now I'm at 51 000 per year he
said 61 or 51.
51. okay
and is that enough to cover your bills
oh yeah definitely okay so you have some
margins I'm pretty Frugal so that's good
do you have any debt
uh I have a car
um a car loan that I owe about 8 500 on
that's going to be paid off this month
oh good okay and that's it for debt
and that's it nothing else how much do
you have in the bank
liquid cash um I've got a I've got about
45 000 in retirement 403b
um I've got 35
000 in a mutual fund
I've got about 40 000 in a savings
account and I'm working on selling about
uh somewhere between 75 and 100 000
worth of
assets and things like that yeah and is
that mutual fund is that just in a
taxable brokerage account it's
non-retirement
correct not a retirement account what
would you think about cashing that out
um so I don't know how it's performing
or anything just yet I think I've had it
open for maybe three months okay and
then George let me just ask a quick
question here the margin uh on your 32
hours when you get paid uh how much
margin do you have I know you're Frugal
uh how much do you have left over after
all the bills
uh well I automatically will put half of
my paycheck in the savings account and
half of it covers everything that I that
I need to pay plus some I usually add a
little extra okay so that's what I
thought and the reason that I asked that
is really to address your initial
question
which is you know how long can you
afford to keep working 32 hours a week
if I understood you correctly yeah and
the answer is you can afford to do it
now you're comfortable my goodness I
mean you get 40 000 in savings I know
what George is going to tell you about
paying off that car today
yeah well that's sort of the plan
um I've been as I've been selling things
that that same account jumped that
really really quickly I think you can
afford to work 32 hours a week as long
as you choose to
okay you're not you're not silly you're
in great financial position wouldn't you
say George oh yeah you said you're 41.
yes
Okay so we've got an investment
calculator over at ramseysolutions.com I
want you to play with that and then get
in touch with it at smartvestor Pro to
help you create a retirement goal
because crunching the numbers here user
41 at 61. you said you have 45 000 in
retirement
and let's say we were able to add you
think you could add 800 a month to that
oh easily okay so at a nine percent
return over that 20 years it'll become
eight hundred thousand now my goal for
you would be to have over a million so
that you can retire fairly comfortably
with net without a house payment do you
have a mortgage right now
no house is paid for wow what's that
worth it that's awesome
um in this market it's probably worth
about 275. okay yeah you're in great
shape so if you've got no payments in
the world after you pay off this car
today which I'm so excited for you to do
as soon as you get off the phone Laura
right
it would be fun to pay it off on the air
so James we got to figure out how to do
that sometime
yeah he's on it he's working on it so
Laura if you did let's say 900 a month
and you worked till 63 you would have
over a million and that's with a nine
percent return uh which is reasonable
and so I have a lot of faith that you
can retire with a lot of dignity
especially because you don't have a
house payment without question and your
income is only going to go up over 20
years right yeah even if you remain to
32 hours and so you're in great shape
and you've got 35 in the mutual fund
you're going to sell off these assets uh
you can invest that money once you sell
those assets as well since you already
have a paid for a house your next goal
is just to continue to build wealth be
generous and also spend some money and
enjoy your life I know you're Frugal
which tells me you probably don't have a
lot of quote fun
now I do what do you do for fun that
costs money
that cost money
for somebody that's not when's the last
time you did that
um a couple of months ago okay awesome
look at George trying to spend your
money I'm trying to have some fun I got
your back over here I'm not gonna let
him get crazy with your money well I'm
I'm excited for the future Laura I know
the the past has been dark for you but
I'm hoping for brighter things ahead and
a great retirement so good thank you so
much proud of her yeah I mean now let's
just I want to pause here and just point
out that Laura having Financial Peace to
the level that she does certainly helps
when you when you when you lose a spouse
oh yeah that's that is so devastating
it's hard enough on its own but then to
add on to that Financial stress how am I
going to pay the bills yeah she's going
to be fine and and uh I love that she's
traveling and and getting back out there
and doing life and wow tough stuff 45.
it's heavy too soon all right we're
going to take a quick one from Amanda
here Amanda get straight to your
question how can we help today
yeah so my husband and I are coming into
about twenty thousand dollars here in
the next few days and um we're just
wondering how to best apply it to our
baby steps we've we're on baby step two
but we've had some recent vehicle
trouble and so we are not sure exactly
what we need to do are the vehicles in
the shop
s well they're not in the shop so we
have the vehicle situation actually
under control right now but there's one
that still needs a little bit of work
um but they're both very much hoopties
um one's a 2008 Dodge Caravan the other
one's a 2001 Lexus RX 300. okay and how
much debt do you have
we have about 32 000 left what kind of
debt is it
it is some student loans the rest of our
timeshare that is that I want to talk
about it and
um a little bit on a credit card okay I
would continue doing the debt snowball
how much do you guys have in the bank in
cash
um we have our thousand dollar emergency
fund and
um I mean I just got paid today so we
have a little bit more than that I
suppose but
um that's for the monthly bills and
stuff okay well you can create a syncing
Fund in your budget for these car
repairs but I would not go out and buy
uh you know ten thousand dollar car
tomorrow because you're worried about
what could happen with these cars so I
would create a sinking fund where you
say all right we're gonna put a hundred
bucks away every month into a savings
account to cover this car repair because
a year from now we're probably going to
have a thousand dollar repair on our
hands right and if you do have a repair
pause the debt snowball cash flow it
work side jobs whatever you got to do to
cash flow it and then get back on the
wagon and continue that dead snowball
but pay them off smallest to largest
with that 20 grand and uh don't let it
derail you with this kind of car these
car troubles
[Music]
absolutely thanks so much for the call
more of your calls coming up give us one
triple eight eight two five five two two
five I'm George camel he's Ken Coleman
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
first Timothy 1 5. the aim of our charge
is love that issues from a pure heart
and a good conscience and a sincere
faith
Abraham Lincoln said perhaps a man's
character is like a tree and his
reputation like its shadow the shadow is
what we think of it the tree is the real
thing
I'm George Campbell joined by Ken
Coleman the sour open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jane joins us up next in Houston Texas
Jane welcome to the show
hey guys thanks so much for having me I
appreciate it absolutely how can Ken and
I help
wow
um it's a real bummer because
corporations have gone up significantly
since we bought the car
luckily he
was really diligent in finding comps and
so Insurance paid us properly in my
opinion
um
given that we had a ten thousand dollar
note on the car at the time it was
stolen and so now we've taken away 26
000 from insurance
um the loans paid off and we have 26 000
sitting in the bank we can't buy the
same car with that twenty six thousand I
don't really want to take on more debt
um currently we're a one-car family and
it's kind of Weighing on us we both work
really long hours but different
schedules kind of I mean really the same
schedule but we both just depending on
our days at work have different hours
basically
um I might have to work till eight
o'clock at night he will get done at 6
30 or vice versa just depending on
um the day so it's been a lot of uber a
lot of ubering basically my question is
do we just buy a junker hold on James
the difference from a junker to a 30 000
car is very large there's a spectrum
there yeah why not buy a 20 000 car is
that a junker to you
well I guess I don't know I don't really
know what we could find for twenty
thousand dollars our answer is no
replacement twenty thousand dollar cars
how what's your income
um combined we make about three ten okay
and so for y'all a twenty thousand
dollar car is a junker because you make
that much money I am on uh I feel bad
because I have a really nice car so it's
so bad where is your money going Jane
that you can't afford to cash flow a
thirty thousand dollar car
um well we can afford a thirty thousand
dollar car but we can't afford
I guess like we couldn't afford to
replace him his car with the Tahoe that
he had before yeah but we're not doing
that we're not doing that we're getting
what George is saying I I okay first of
all you got to go to basic car website
Facebook Marketplace and just look in
your area uh in a budget range of 20
just through 20 and or fifteen thousand
I mean depending on what your financial
goals are but do you guys have a lot of
jokers
we do we have student loans yeah okay
how much
uh about 97 000. yeah but look at a ten
thousand dollar car a 15 if you're
trying to cut back and use some of that
cash to go to the student loans but you
gotta have I guess that's what I was
asking is should we buy like a ten
thousand dollar car and put the rest of
it towards the student loans yes or
should we love that plan yes because
that car is not your Forever car that
might be a one-year car and you sell it
and you upgrade once you're completely
debt free with an emergency fund and you
can easily cash flow a 35
000 car making 310.
once you have no debt right
yeah that's what we could save up for
one at least why don't you go on again
go online and just search cars between
seven and ten thousand and just see
what's out there you don't even know
trust me I know the reason I know is I
gotta I got a kid who needs a car all
right uh a teenager and so I've been
looking I'm looking all the time you'll
be surprised what you can get that's
highly functional
I'm pulling up just Tahoes and seeing in
my area what I can get for twenty
thousand dollars for example but we're
not doing 20 George we've already got
her down to 10. well even down to 15 you
can get a 2013 Tahoe so I think the
problem is expectations versus reality
you just don't know and that's not being
negative you just haven't looked you
gotta look but you guys had a brand new
Tahoe pretty much what was the year on
it it was a 2016. okay so 2016 going
down to a 2013 feels like a downgrade
and that's hard emotionally for you guys
but she's looking at a sedan I'm telling
you my thing of Jane is I think you guys
need to take control of your income and
go where is this 310 000 going because
if we can clean up we've been cash
flowing uh different project recently
and so that's kind of where some of it's
been going okay and we're we're able to
shift back now to our debts but we're
just trying to figure out what do we do
with this pile of cash do we buy a car
or do we stay a one-car family I think
you need the two cars you need a car you
spent the first two minutes in distress
over the one car it's not worth it you
guys make 310 000 get a reasonable car
for now pay off the debt get the
emergency fund and then we can upgrade
the car yep
okay that's simple simple simple simple
and yes it's going to take some
swallowing of the pride to go I don't
really love this car it's okay it's a
car it gets from A to B without having
to do Uber that's it yeah
so but that stinks about the stolen
vehicle that's a tough situation that's
really true that's tough oof glad
Insurance took care of them all right
you're the insurance Guru I love
insurance and Lynn's up next in
Cincinnati Lynn how are you
hi I'm good thank you what's going on
with you so Mike yes so my question is I
have about ten thousand dollars in a
life insurance policy my husband passed
away in 2020 and I have a parent plus
one of thank you
um I have a parent plus loan that I owe
20 or 12 000 on
and so my question is
and I need a new vehicle but I've
decided to wait I put a little bit of
money like 1500 of that pen into
um you know just getting the car out to
the car and hoping to get me through two
or three years should I put the rest of
that money down on the Parent PLUS Loan
um I do have about a thousand dollars a
month set aside
um in my budget to put towards the
Parent PLUS Loan I just started this
whole budget scene with you guys so
um
yes welcome to the weirdos who budget
yeah
right okay so you're doing the right
things do you have any other debt other
than the parent plus loan
mortgage which is you know 80 000. I had
to sell my home that we were living in
and I you know bought a new home that's
something I could afford myself okay so
yeah so 1500 everything is going on that
house I could
yeah that's great or we're gonna worry
about that later on in what we call baby
step six and so right now baby step two
we're paying off the debt which is the
parent plus loan you said you're gonna
put 1500 into the repairs to get the car
functional for the next few years
yes and then 8 500 towards the Parent
PLUS Loan which gets it down to 3 500.
yes and then putting a thousand a month
is that on top of the minimum payment
um that includes the minimum payment
okay so in the next four months you're
completely debt free
if you follow this plan and then you can
start building your emergency fund which
is three to six months of expenses do
you know what that would add up to
um yes I think it was about I added it
up once before and I think it was close
to like maybe twelve thousand perfect
and so that's our next goal and that
thousand you were spending on The Parent
PLUS Loan can now go go towards the
emergency fund and so I would love for
you to have that emergency fund within
six months
what's your income that would be great
um so I bring home about
the every
everything okay
right
and so with that you know 2600 a month
we're going to try to limit our expenses
as much as we can if you can do any
overtime or I'll work on the side to
increase that I want to get you that
Financial Foundation as soon as possible
so that you can begin investing are you
investing right now
um not really I mean I work for a school
system and so my retirement is set up
through them and I'm you know 52 years
old I I'm about ready to I can retire
now
but because of all that's happened in
the last two years I'm not retiring yet
oh I understand so well we want to get
you to a great financial spot so what
I'm going to do is gift you one year of
Financial Peace University as well as
every dollar our budgeting tool because
you've already got started on that and
we want to walk with you over the next
year as you build that foundation so
sorry for your loss and we're wishing
you the best on this journey thanks so
much for the call that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show in the books my thanks
to my co-host Mr Ken Coleman and all the
folks in the booth we've got Austin and
James and Andrew and Zach the whole
gang's in there and you America thank
you for listening in we'll be back with
you before you know it until then spend
wisely save intentionally and give
generously good show
[Music]
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]